which Disney villain are you because
let's face it penises are boring hey
guys we are at BuzzFeed we are the cast
of descendants - I am Duff Cameron I am
china anne mcclain and I am Sophie of
course and we're going to take the which
Disney villain are you quiz I just want
to point out that this is a really
awesome visual oh yeah our epic mothers
oh yeah take a look at that because how
apik are they okay okay what is your
greatest quality I mean ambitious yeah I
would say being sinister I was about to
say that to echo what sinister Ubu
that's what do you move what is your
ideal lair Oh a castle on top of a
mountain unmeet go with a castle deep in
the woods good one outlet wild yes
no why did you describe your style these
are really about a lot of good ones I'm
kind of a clean elegant but powerful a
beautiful and regal mysterious I would
go with are you in the Perseus yes
beautiful Queen
how do you prefer your sidekick
sidekicks are very important kids
usually be insane ones are the best ones
no no looks like wisecracking I'm gonna
need that all day somebody's knocking
but what if you're trying to like be
maniacal he keeps telling jokes and
you're just like let's feel in my body
it will be me that makes them makes for
good comedy thanks for a good movie but
yeah you know that show though well
we'll see but you know me like I don't
ever get I'm always
wisecracking I'm so annoying I'm your
little insane sidekick I'm sane
wisecracking annoying that's okay
you can't say anything I can say he's
kidding all three though I would say
wisecracking
I'm gonna go ice or insane I haven't
gone I'm saying sidekick would it be
helpful Oh what is the best motivation
to be evil so many I hope I could never
access anything for revenge and I hear
that Tina Howard I don't care enough cuz
jealousy is just insecure age as this
fight I don't I don't do well what keep
you're doing me wrong no I probably
going for ribbing okay China
why so it's funny here
my commentary is killing me let's go
quick given how many go without of pride
we've got a protein power what is the
best accessory Oh villain can have like
I'm in the middle look to like genuine
villains you heart a staff
sorry guys yeah the best accessories I'm
gonna go with a cold drink as I can
poison apples in the cauldron yeah none
for me because how am I gonna room
have a cold room would be like trying to
be evil walking around with it :
okay which of these powers is the best
the ability of metamorphosis has
menopause okay okay I'm sorry I don't
think I believe as much expose you guys
right now you can have you anything you
can do guys when I go this phone as well
what are you power colors black and gray
black and gray red is a good color I
mean look like anime what is your weapon
of choice a henchman
I'll get a henchman I'm gonna go with
the High Elves I got no need to get my
magic of course and we'll go with
magical arts transformation okay because
think about it you're like tell me how
it's a good deep under surprise
formation yeah
or you can also just want to look like
Angelina Jolie one day they're like I
wish I look like and then you do yeah so
you know what I'm going with that on
both the counselors pack which of these
do you hate the most true love made at
Beauty Hayden family and not being
included or those with more power
yo baby power I love people way too much
time on the outsides and leg which is
the best way to get back to your enemies
embarrassing that put a curse on them
emotionally manipulating them
emotionally the manipulating one of
their loved ones or killing them but if
they killing them is too easy of it and
also if you kill them you can't get back
at them exactly put a curse on one
torture I think it's more torturous
emotionally would be one of the ones
that's the worst card whoa that's some
stuff that like touch a part of me your
baby this fear is sorted through the
heart falling off a cliff having a
boulder fall on you yeah
being is wrapped in a small space for
the
lightning no it was some really
uncomfortable occult stuff I
deal-breaker for me by Laini oh come on
if both of you guys got your people this
gonna be embarrassed sorry guys I got
the evil queen
I'm sorry's me guys I mean they do say
that Maleficent is the most evil of them
all so I am the daughter of the Evil
Queen's that makes sense that I got my
mother
[Music]